und da ist der bundesfinanzminister
guten abend herr lindner guten abend
frau slomka r hält man die politik
befürchtet dass wir in heißen herbst
bekommen viele menschen gucken mit angst
darauf was der heizkosten rechnungen sie
erwarten werden das ist wirklich eine
kritische situation passt dass da in die
landschaft eine steuer bereinigung zu
machen die vor allem den
besserverdienenden zu gute kommt sie
kommen nicht vor allem den
besserverdienenden zu gute sondern es
ist ein verzicht auf eine
steuererhöhungen die sonst heimlich
stattfinden würde aber lassen sie uns
die dinge gerne sortieren in diesem jahr
haben wir zwei große entlastungs pakete
geschnürt die umfassende einmalzahlungen
für hartz-iv-empfänger die umfassen
einen zuschuss für wohngeldempfänger
rückwirkende steuerentlastungen im
nächsten jahr wird es eine große
wohngeldreform geben und wir werden die
lebenssituation von menschen in der
grundsicherung durch das neue bürger
gelte jetzt fahren
steuertarif erneuert ich wollte es eben
im zusammenhang darstellen wir haben auf
der einen seite menschen die unsere
solidarität brauchen und wir haben auf
der anderen seite die arbeitende mitte
in unserem land die viel an steuern und
sozialabgaben zahlen und die möchte ich
schützen vor einer automatischen
steuererhöhungen wenn wir nichts tun
werden 48 millionen deutsche um zehn
milliarden euro in der inflation
belastet und das muss abgewendet werden
die gesamtsumme betrachtet ist das dann
zum teil gar nicht so viel aber
entscheidend ist ja die
verteilungswirkung die das hat also wenn
ich wenig verdiene überhaupt keine
steuern zahle habe ich davon schon mal
gar nichts das sind aber die die momente
echte installation ja besonders
getroffen werden dann wenn man sich den
tarif anguckt bis 25.000 euro hat man
halt sein 213 euro entlastungen und wenn
man viel verdient 100.000 euro und mehr
dann bekommt man über 670 euro
entlastung das ist eine
verteilungswirkung dieser tarif hat
hätte man da nicht etwas anders dran
schrauben können also menschen
brauchen moment eigentlich keine
entlastung die kriegen ihre bude schon
geheizt frau slomka um die menschen die
ihre bude nicht geheizt bekommen da
kümmern wir uns ja mit dem neuen
wohngeld und es gibt bürger geld für die
menschen in grundsicherung aber hier
geht es nun darum
nichts anderes zu tun als unser
steuersystem anzupassen an die inflation
die starken schultern werden weiter auch
eine große last tragen aber sie werden
eben nicht stärker belastet und vor
allen dingen sorgen wir dafür dass nicht
menschen die in wahrheit keine breiten
schultern haben durch die inflation
plötzlich mehr steuern zahlen ist eine
reine inflationsanpassung diese zehn
milliarden gehen zum größten teil eben
an die höheren einkommen rechnen
aber rein rechnerisch zahlen die höheren
einkommen eben auch das gros des
steueraufkommens jemand der keine
steuern zahlt den kann ich natürlich
auch nicht im steuerrecht in irgendeiner
form profitieren lassen das geht nicht
sondern hier geht es darum
steuererhöhungen abzuwenden aber und da
war ihre zahl eben unrichtig ich habe
einen deckel eingezogen bei
62.000 euro jahreseinkommen endet die
zusätzliche
entlastung bzw ab dort gibt es keinen
zusätzlichen vorteil mehr es genau das
ein wirklich euro im vergleich dazu hat
bereits den euro stimmt doch nein die
maximale entlastung bei einem bei einem
bei einer einzelnen person sind 62.000
euro jahreseinkommen bei 479 euro da ist
das gedeckelt und das ist das 1,5 fache
etwa das 1,5 fache des mittleren
einkommens in deutschland ab diesem
punkt gibt es keine weitere entlastung
bzw ab da verschieben wir verschiebe ich
den tarifverlauf nicht nach namen habe
ich dann eine eine wichtige information
noch geben die kalte progression ist in
den letzten gut zehn jahren immer
ausgeglichen worden ein
sozialdemokratischer vorgänger hat sogar
noch den letzten tarif wert auf
277.000 euro erhöht ich als liberaler
finanzminister sagen wir machen einen
deckel bei 62.000 euro und deshalb sage
ich das ist sozial ausgewogen umgekehrt
muss man sagen die menschen die 34 5000
euro verdienen ihre heizkosten selbst
bezahlen auch unter der inflation leiden
gleichzeitig noch steuern und
sozialabgaben in erheblichem umfang
zahlen die wollen wir noch stärker über
das steuerrecht belasten durch
unterlassung das kann ich nicht fair
finden das steuerrecht muss einen
ausgleich bringen zwischen den menschen
an ada ried empfangen und die alles
bezahlen aber bei der mehrwertsteuer
stört sie das ja auch nicht dass der
staat sich dann quasi durch die
inflation bereichert um sie zu zitieren
ja aber in der tat nutzen wir ja die
möglichkeiten etwa mit einmalzahlungen
wie der energiepreis pauschale in diesem
jahr mit
heizkostenzuschuss um den ausgleich zu
machen um auf inflations gewinne zu
verzichten haben wir in diesem jahr ja
bereits auch den tank rabatz gemacht
damit die leute die höhere spritpreise
bezahlen nicht auch noch über höhere
mehrwertsteuer die staatskasse füllen
dass manche sagen dieser tank rabatt ist
das nicht die gratis mentalität von der
sie in bezug auf das neue euro ticket
sprachen ich glaube an der zapfsäule
sieht man dass das sehr teuer ist das
auto vollzutanken
gerade für die pendlerinnen und pendler
und ich hätte es nicht gerecht gefunden
dass die menschen den höheren
weltmarktpreis für den sprit bezahlen
auf diesen höheren preis kommt noch die
mehrwertsteuer und füllt die kasse des
finanzministers aber einige konzerne
gewinnen dadurch aber eine über gewinn
steuer wollen sie auch nicht machen die
konzerne wie etwa bp heißen ja nicht
bayerisch petroleum sondern british
petroleum oder beyond petroleum heute
die haben ihren sitz nicht in
deutschland
wir haben in unserem land über gewinne
wenn man das so nennen will also sehr
hohe gewinne bei impfstoff produzenten
wir haben hohe gewinne auch bei denen
bei den produzenten von von windkraft
aber wenn der staat beginnt zu
entscheiden welcher gewinn ist
akzeptabel und welcher nicht liefern wir
unser steuerrecht der willkür aus und
übrigens beschädigen wir auch den
innovationsstandort deutschland denn wir
wollen ja innovative unternehmen die
biotech bei uns haben die briten hat
kein problem mit und die inder sage ich
schon die italiener schaffen es auch
sehr gut dieses gewinnverlagerung
problem zu umgehen indem sie den umsatz
besteuern also man könnte schon wenn man
wollte wer genau hinsieht stellt fest
dass es in italien große probleme bei
der erhebung gibt und in frankreich hat
sich das parlament
gerade aus diesen gründen gegen eine
über gewinn steuer entschieden herr
littmann danke für das gespräch ich
danke ihnen auch
[Musik]